what's going on guys this is rob and it
occurred to me recently that we never
finished dan slot's run on spider-man
now for those of you guys who don't know
what that means dan slott had a very
lengthy run on spider-man it started
with big time which is where i usually
always tell people to start whenever it
is they want to start reading spider-man
it goes into stuff like spider island a
lot of the stories that you've heard of
over the years and then it went into all
new all different marvel went into
superior spider-man all kinds of
different things so here's what we're
gonna do with this video we're gonna
take the first comic we're gonna break
it off we're gonna do some retreading
ground on things that we that we've
already done because it's been so long
and then we're going to probably do the
other four comics by themselves right
because clone conspiracy is a five issue
series right five issue miniseries this
whole thing basically comes after before
dead no more and before dead no more was
basically a story that was written by
dan slott where by some strange way all
these different people who had died over
the life of spider-man uh not everyone
who had died but a lot of these people
who had died over the course of peter
parker's life at spider-man had started
popping up and it basically turned out
that it was miles warren the jackal who
was basically doing it now one of the
big moments that came from this came
with the return of vanessa who was the
wife of the kingpin who had long since
been dead kingpin picked up right off
the bat that it was not his vanessa and
he basically killed the clone but miles
warren had basically been resurrecting
people or cloning people and then
passing them off as the originals right
so what this does is this initially
picks up with the death of jay jameson
senior now jay jamison senior of course
as you imagine is the father of jay
jonah jameson the guy that's always
making those news scenes and hates
spider-man in more recent years jay
jonah jameson has actually become an
ally of spider-man which took place
during dan slot's run it was a huge
change of pace for the character but jay
jameson senior had actually married aunt
may right so he was peter parker's
stepdad by all standards of measurement
and a long and
strong relationship had formed between
the two and it was cool right it was a
pretty interesting change but one of the
things that goes on here is that for jay
jamison senior he was actually dying of
natural causes there wasn't really
anything peter parker had done that had
led to him dying he hadn't sustained any
kind of mortal injuries and you know his
collateral damage in a fight between
like peter parker and dr octopus it was
basically just old age and for peter
parker it still hits him just the same
and the reason why is because for the
second time in his life he's standing
next to his aunt may helping her grieve
over the loss of a husband once was bad
enough and again the death of uncle ben
was probably the single most important
death in the history of the spider-man
mythos because it taught him the price
to be paid for doing nothing when you
could do something and so having to sit
next to aunt may and relive this entire
experience is kind of crushing for peter
now i don't mean to say this is all
about him right peter's a narcissist i
don't really mean to say that it's just
it's a crushing experience to have to
endure that because this was yet another
instance when peter could have done
something that would have saved the life
of jay jamison senior and of course this
leads to his son jay jonah freaking out
on peter parker and losing on him and
the reason why is because he says like
you were the one who talked my father
and your aunt may out of the treatments
that could have saved his life like it's
because of you that he's dead he could
have lived had he undergone those
treatments now all this really begins to
kind of get fleshed out and it's
explained to us by way of a character
named anna maria marconi now for people
who are familiar with our coverage of
the spider-man run by dan slot or those
of you guys who have read it you guys
know who anna marconi is for those of
you guys who don't know anna maria
marconi knows peter parker is spider-man
and the reason for this all goes back to
superior spider-man right so superior
spider-man was basically a story dan
slott wrote where you ended up learning
over the course of a pretty lengthy
period of time that one dr octopus's
body was breaking down due to all the
experiments he'd done on himself and
just the overall toll that his actions
had taken on his physical form and so
what he intended to do was was continue
his survival by in effect taking his
consciousness and putting it the body of
peter parker and that's where you get
superior spider-man now during that time
it was really kind of a redemption story
for doc ock because up to that point he
had a few different moments here and
there where he had like saved the life
of peter parker or something like that
or it helped peter parker with some kind
of science or something along those
lines but by and large he was always
still a villain in general what superior
spider-man did is it changed a few
things one it really introduced to us
the idea that peter parker had been
pulling his punches all those times like
literally there's one point where dr
octopus faces off against the scorpion
and punches his jaw off of his face and
realizes holy cow peter parker's been
been like holding like he's been pulling
his punches all the time he could have
killed us at any point in time it's
amazing that he didn't
the other part of it is that because uh
dr octopus or superior spider-man came
across anna marconi she was the one that
actually kind of helped him to redeem
himself right to help him realize
there's more to life than just like
robbing banks or trying to kill
spider-man or something along those
lines and so because of anna marconi's
moral influence on dr octopus he
actually started becoming a superhero
and so one of the things that he did is
he he expanded the technology that peter
parker used as minor as it was to help
to really make him a more effective
spider-man now it was really done for
doc ock himself as superior spider-man
because his thought was i can't be
everywhere at once but i can develop
little spider bots that can be
everywhere at once and alert me of
anything that's going on and if it
doesn't require my attention i can
notify the cops uh the other thing that
happened here is he basically started
developing parker industries and parker
industries was kind of a think tank a
continuation of what was called horizon
labs which was the think tank that peter
parker was originally part of just a
great big huge collection of geniuses
and then as superior spider-man dr
octopus developed parker industries to
be a kind of expansive almost worldwide
organization that could basically better
humanity right it was just a huge change
of pace the big thing about this is that
anna marconi if i remember correctly
didn't know that dr octopus was in the
body of peter parker she just thought it
was peter parker right she didn't really
know the difference ultimately when
peter got his body back there was a huge
amount of confusion going on with anna
marconi because of how he was acting
because she was asking him about things
that peter parker didn't have any
recollection of because it was dr
octopus controlling his body instead of
peter and so ultimately peter had to
come clean and he had to tell her okay
look here's everything that went on that
guy was not actually me that was it was
a guy who was in control of my body i'm
peter parker yes i'm spider-man yadda
yadda and that's how she ended up
finding out his identity right so it was
a really really good story but the
reason why peter here is is focusing on
the fact that he could have saved uh jay
jameson senior is because there came a
point during his illness when j jameson
senior was approached by a company
called new you technologies now the idea
behind this was that at a previous point
in time there was a great big huge
explosion right that you know this might
be a huge thing that took place out in
oklahoma and that one of the workers uh
well really was at a parker at parker
industries plant but one of the workers
named jerry salteras was injured and so
new you technologies approached him and
his family with the possibility of
basically giving him the kind of uh
transplants and things he needed in
order to survive which they went with
the problem was as soon as the
experiment was done and peter met with
jerry salteras because he was a member
of parker industries right an employee
of the company peter went to go shake
his hand and his spider sense went crazy
peter didn't know what it meant he had
no idea what it meant he just knew that
something was wrong and based on that
flimsy piece of evidence at that moment
in time he used that as a reason to talk
jay jamison senior and aunt may out of
new you technologies just because of the
fact that it was in effect his own hunch
right it was his gut telling him
something was wrong and that's kind of a
big thing to go on right especially with
somebody like peter now granted there is
a measure of acceptance there that peter
kind of looks at that and says okay my
spider sense has never done me wrong so
even if i don't know exactly what's
wrong i know something is wrong this
jerry salteras guy is not the guy i know
there's something going on here with
this guy and basically by kind of
extrapolating that out he could look at
it and say if jay jameson goes through
this this whole procedure i don't know
what's going to happen to him afterwards
he'll probably recover but then
something's going to be wrong something
bad is going to happen i just don't know
what it is and so we ultimately talked
them out of it now the biggest issue
that peter has here and this is really
where he screwed up he didn't really
tell them why he didn't really give them
all the information that they needed to
make an informed decision it was just
aunt may jay jamison senior you can't do
this procedure because we don't really
know a whole lot about their science you
have to just trust me on this and in
reality asking somebody to put their
life on the line uh and and really just
kind of going on the idea that that they
assume that you're giving them all the
information that's pretty shady right
it's kind of a shady thing for peter
parker to do and that's why a lot of
this guilt is weighing on his head
because he just didn't do everything he
was supposed to and so at this point
he's like okay let's kind of go back to
new you and let's investigate this a
little bit more so what he ends up doing
is going back to edmond oklahoma and
visiting with jerry salteras wife the
problem is jerry's not there right jerry
is just kind of vanished and when the
question's why like you know what's
what's going on here then basically his
wife ends up showing him a kind of a
video clip and essentially it's just one
of these things where he's talking about
how he's setting up a camp and all that
kind of good stuff and then he has what
are in effect these kind of illness
moments right these moments where he
experiences a lot of pain and he's like
it'll it'll pass it'll be fine you know
and all that kind of stuff and when the
question is asked of peter what's going
on here peter says it's cellular
degradation right his cells are
basically breaking down and he's like i
think i know what's going on here and so
at that point he basically makes a
promise that he can't keep and that's
one of the cool things about the way
that dan sloth handles spider-man right
when it comes to peter parker what made
him so popular over the years in marvel
comics was the relatability factor right
the fact that he's just like a young kid
who's dead on his luck right the parker
luck the fact that he can never really
seem to catch a break seemingly
everything that can go wrong does go
wrong the reality is when it comes to
peter the emotional empathetic side of
him always seemed to kind of get the
better of him and he would always kind
of find himself in these predicaments
where he would essentially make promises
that he couldn't keep and that's one of
the things that he does here right he
tells this woman you know he tells a
jerry salteras wife we'll get your
husband back and everything is going to
be okay but he can't make that promise
because he's not holding all the cards
he doesn't know everything that's going
on here and even anna calls it on that
she's like look man like i understand
where you're coming from i understand
you want to do the good thing you want
to be the good ceo who runs this company
and cares about his people and that's
fine but you can't make promises that
you cannot keep right you don't know
everything that's going on here but one
of the things that peter kind of has is
an ace up his sleeve or what he had done
is when his fighter since initially went
off after meeting jerry salteras he hit
him with a spider tracker right which is
actually one of the pieces of technology
that dr octopus had developed when he
was superior spider-man but he hits him
with a spider tracker and then uses that
to track his location and while ana
marconi and and the other members of
horizon are basically working on uh
understanding the medicine that jerry
was taking breaking it down on the
cellular level and understanding what
it's actually made of peter is breaking
into new you to basically find jerry the
problem is that once he gets in here he
realizes this is all just like a giant
lap right he literally gets to like one
of these tanks and it looks like the
eyes move for a second but the the
tracking device leads him to this
location the problem is it's all just
nervous system right it's literally just
a body of nerves there's no muscle
there's no sinew no bone no none of that
stuff except for eyeballs and the
eyeballs actually look like they move
for a second which in all reality if a
person was stuck in this condition
they'd have to be experiencing pain
beyond imagining right it would just it
would have either that or the nerves are
basically uh or you know muted the pain
in the nerves is muted and he just
doesn't feel anything the problem is
that as he's investigating then suddenly
it's like this guy walks in and peter's
like what in the heck and he's like oh
my god it's miles warren and as soon as
peter realizes his miles worn he's like
it's a clone thing now here's the reason
why peter realizes that back in the
1990s marvel had this genius idea that
actually turned out to be a three year
long unmitigated disaster that was
called the clone saga
and you talk to anybody who knows
anything about spider-man and they will
tell you that story was bad and marvel
should feel bad the idea behind it was
fantastic that miles warren basically
created clones of peter parker as a
means to kind of eliminate peter
replacing with somebody else and for us
as the reader and even for peter himself
he didn't know if he was the clone he
didn't know if ben riley was the actual
spider-man or if kane was the actual
spider-man there was there was no real
way to know the problem is it ballooned
up from what should have just been like
a six-issue story into a three-year-long
over 100 issue story arc that was 90
unnecessary and full of nonsense but
where miles warren exists a clone
problem has to exist somewhere near it
right that's always been the jackals
thing ever since the events of the
original clone saga and so because that
peter's like okay this is obviously some
kind of clone thing right like he's like
i'm gonna tear your heart out right like
peter gets wildly frustrated and not
necessarily because of the fact that
jackal might be cloning peter that's not
part of it it's because when the jackal
gets involved in stuff like this he
doesn't care who he hurts it doesn't
matter who he involves here right it's
just as long as he can do whatever it is
that he needs to do right it's messing
with people's lives which is a far more
extreme action than like robbing a bank
or something like that as far as peter's
concerned based on his moral compass
tearing a family apart is way worse than
stealing a million dollars from a bank
that's insured and will basically be
given back right i mean at the end of
the day it sucks that they did it but
it's really more the crime the action
they committed they're arrested for not
because people feel bad for the banks
right that's not really what's what's
going on now of course miles warren
calls in security and then you're
basically met by the rhino and the new
electro so as part of this whole lead up
to before dead no more one of the things
that was hap or one of the things that
had happened is that a former girlfriend
had actually been brought back by uh new
you technologies who was basically
somebody max dylan had actually killed
by accident now when she was brought
back she had actually kissed electro and
basically siphoned off all of his
electrical power and killed him in the
process and basically absorbed his
abilities so she became the new electro
it was kind of cool it was pretty
interesting marvel never did anything
whether that mattered
but it was kind of interesting but of
course it's one of those things where
peter's like wait a minute so you're a
new electro and she's like yeah and he's
like and rhino's kind of an idiot so
it's like all right i know how to solve
this problem
so while peter's ducking and dodging he
ends up basically going behind or going
to a wall that of course you know was a
barrier between an enormous amount of
water in the facility itself rips it
open like it ends up basically you know
dumping the water supply into this place
and of course water's a perfect current
for electricity ends up taking out
electro and and and rhino now it's one
of the funny things here because if this
was max dylan he would have been like no
no no no and he would have he would have
dodged out of the way because he would
have seen it coming but it's one of the
things that peter says is like that's
the great thing about the new electro
you have no idea about any of the old
tricks and rhino wasn't going to stop me
because he's a [ __ ] so it's
it's one of those funny things because
from there with them out of the way
peter basically starts making his way
through uh through the new use facility
trying to find miles warren only to be
met with gwen stacy and this blew my
mind when this happened because my
initial thought was okay so this is
obviously a clone but it's obviously a
clone that's going on here but here's
the kicker whenever peter comes across
these clones it sets his spider sense
off with gwen stacy it doesn't and so
what it looks like is it is actually
gwen stacy that's the thought right it
is really gwen stacy which is a huge
deal why because gwen stacy was the
first real girlfriend that peter parker
had technically there was betty brandt
but you know they were more knocking
boots right friends with benefits if you
really want to call it that gwen stacy
was the first real love of peter parker
right like in love head over heels his
and hers towels sharing stuff you know
sharing the bathroom right she's
bringing her toothbrush and toothpaste
over and a few changes of clothes right
like we're in it now like that that was
gwen stacy right that was gwen stacy for
peter parker the crazy thing about this
is gwen stacy died right 1971 written by
jerry conway the night when stacey died
that was a story that changed peter
parker entirely right because one of the
things that the idea of uncle ben dying
was significant because the top peter
with great power must come great
responsibility right the lessons of his
uncle ben rang true with the death of
when stacy it taught peter parker he
can't be reckless that was so important
that was a wildly important thing
because depending on who you talk to and
even the comic itself is a little murky
right like when stacy falls off the
bridge peter parker shoots his webbing
into her foot you hear this you like
literally just says like crack so the
indication is that peter parker broke
her neck by uh by shooting his webbing
into her foot this just like the jerk
snapped her neck but then the green
goblins like she was already dead before
you got here so it's kind of murky right
you don't really know if if peter parker
was the one who got gwen stacy killed or
if the the green goblin had already
killed her but regardless of the
situation the death of gwen stacy taught
peter parker you cannot be reckless with
your powers and so that was huge because
following that of course uh mary jane
watson came into the mix and the two of
them ended up forming a relationship but
the idea of gwen stacy being here is
nuts because it totally takes peter
parker by surprise and that matters
because immediately his spider sense
goes off and he's like okay my spider
sense is not related to her because if
it was it would have already been going
off the problem is he doesn't catch it
why because he's clunked over the head
with the tentacles of dr octopus who has
officially returned to marvel comics
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this to an end
and i will catch you all in the next
video peace